this is a chart showing estimated
population around the year 1750 in the
British colonies in the New World
I've arranged this more or less from
north to south and you can see that as
you go farther south the percentage of
the population that was enslaved and
African grew greater and greater but one
thing to note here is that not any one
of these colonies had zero enslaved
people at all even New Hampshire the
farthest north with the smallest
percentage of enslaved Africans had some
enslaved people there before the
American Revolution we frequently have
the misconception that slavery only
happened in the south in fact all
British colonies had some amount of
slavery and all British colonies had
some involvement in the institution of
slavery whether that was bankrolling it
as a financier growing food that was
intended for the slave colonies in the
West Indies that didn't want to spare
even an acre of land to grow something
other than sugar or shipping enslaved
Africans by either owning or captaining
the boats of the Middle Passage in fact
one of the largest ports where slaves
entered the North American colonies and
were sold at auction was at Newport
Rhode Island but despite this the
largest share of enslaved people were in
the southern colonies which focused on
plantation agriculture so Maryland
Virginia and then even farther south
into the British colonies in the
Caribbean in some of these southernmost
colonies you can see that enslaved
Africans outnumbered white people by
sometimes quite a considerable amount as
the enslaved population in the colonies
grew colonial governments began passing
more and more restrictions on the lives
of enslaved people and began codifying
who was or was not a slave for example
a white man and an enslaved woman had a
child together would that child be free
like her father or enslaved like her
mother what about the opposite case in
Virginia in 1662 the government passed a
law specifying that the children of
enslaved women would follow the
condition of their mothers other laws
prevented interracial relationships and
defined enslaved Africans as chattel
slaves which means personal property and
as the personal property of slave owners
enslaved people had little to no legal
rights so over the course of the 1600s
slavery became stricter and more
exclusively defined by race the
experience of being enslaved was
unimaginably physically and emotionally
taxing since enslaved people had no
legal protections owners could maim or
even kill enslaved people with little to
no repercussion for women life and
slavery also meant the constant threats
and frequent reality of rape at the
hands of slave owners religion dance
music and family helped enslaved people
deal with the harsh realities of
everyday life and enslaved people also
developed both covert means of resisting
slavery like for example breaking tools
which made it more difficult to work or
overt means of resisting slavery
particularly in slave uprisings one of
these the Stono rebellion in 1739 in
south carolina resulted in the deaths of
about 42 whites and about 44 blacks the
South Carolina government responded to
the rebellion by making slave codes even
harsher I want to finish by just
reiterating how central the institution
of slavery was to not just some but all
of the English colonies in the
nineteenth century Americans would refer
to slavery as
the peculiar institution meaning not so
much that it was strange but that it was
specific to the south part of the United
States but slavery really wasn't
specific to the south part it was the
bedrock of the colonial economy not just
in the South but in all the industries
that contributed to slavery in the north
as well those who financed fed shipped
and even bought the products made by
enslaved people created the economic
prosperity of the North American
colonies